Center Wells Senior Primary Care the
sponsors of this segment is back to talk
emotional and mental Wellness for older
adults
hi Dr Wakefield welcome back hey Rocky
it's great to see you good to see you
too thank you so much for taking care of
our seniors obviously physical health is
so important but we want to focus now on
the mental and emotional health why why
are these aspects of our seniors health
so important we're uh well our health is
interconnected and as a physician at
Center well when I ask you you know how
are you feeling I mean it not only your
body but your emotions your
relationships Financial Health because
we know it's all lean seniors who are
active social and connective how we know
how better long-term Health outcomes
right right and what do you mean by or
Define further what social health is
so it's all about relationships right
and these include not only our friends
our family our neighbors and more
relationships are important at any time
in our lives but especially so as we age
which for many people you know people as
often when social connections start to
decrease you know we're less active we
may not be working anymore and our
friends may move away or even pass away
that breaks my heart and you know what
are some of the biggest factors that
seniors are facing when dealing with
their social well-being or when wanting
to improve it yeah so one issue we
really see in our seniors is isolation
we know that isolated seniors tend to
experience more health issues and are
prone to faster cognitive decline that's
why at Center well we look at
maintaining social Wellness as an
important dimension of preventative care
and what are some of the signs that we
should look out for for seniors that are
dealing with social well-being well no
one should spend long periods of time in
isolation if you know a senior who's
spending too much time alone offer to
spend time with them and share your
concerns with maybe their doctor or
their family other signs may include you
know depressed mood changes in their
eating habits or hygiene problems with
memory you may even see some substance
abuse and social withdrawal
wow and what can seniors do to maintain
the good social health
so one thing we offer is you can contact
one of our centers and ask for a
calendar of events and activities each
of our locations has an activity center
which really is a hub for our seniors
not just our patients you can visit you
know time to chat have coffee see people
other good activities seniors may want
to get involved with could include arts
and crafts low impact exercise they
could even visit an animal shelter or a
petting zoo playing table games and
really just spending times Outdoors is
often helpful definitely and can
technology help as well
well we know that definitely many of our
seniors are on social media and are
comfortable with technology which they
can use to not only make new friends but
also reconnect with old friends overall
though we want to think of these mobile
devices as more as support and not
really a substitute for that
face-to-face interaction
thank you Center well senior primary
care for sponsoring that segment head to
centerwell lasvegas.com for more
information we'll be right back